Puberty. Bar Mitzvah. Bat Mitzvah.
Quinceanera. The commencement of
adulthood. Graduation ceremony and
literally a commencement. You're gonna
get married? You have a wedding. You're
gonna have a birth? You have a baby
shower. You die? This is Bali, one of my
favorite places. You die and you have a
funeral. But between baby shower and
funeral? Nada.
Nothing. Why is that? It is because in the
year 1900, longevity in the United States
was 47 years old. And it was a lot less
in a lot of other places. So midlife,
as a premise, didn't make sense.
Midlife was 24 years, 25 years old or
something like that. So the thing is, 1965
is the year that "midlife crisis" as a
phrase, or it was coined, that phrase was
coined by a psychologist. And it is now 54
years later from when we
coined that term, and we've done very
little to solve it.